ladies and gentlemen this year's
nominees for actor and actress in a
leading role
Jeff Bridges
Sandra Bullock
George Clooney
helen mirren
colin firth
Carey Mulligan
Morgan Freeman
Gabourey Sidibe
jeremy renner
Meryl Streep
live from the Kodak Theatre at Hollywood
and Highland
it's the 82nd annual Academy Awards
and now the moment you've all been
waiting for
good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the 82nd annual Academy
Awards I'm Neil Patrick Harris I know
what am I doing here
why wouldn't Crosby give up hope why
does Harold call Kumar when he scores
dope and why does a prisoner drop the
soap cause no one wants to do it alone
can't imagine Cinderella without the
ball for the battling burdens without a
brawl can't think about Botox without
you all no one wants to do
can't take Julie a child from her pi4
take James Cameron from his CG I you
have to share billing you have to share
Fame
there's someone to share the blame this
is why Chin's are loved her Fred it's
why Warren Beatty stayed in bed so ever
Team Jacob 4G
you're just a lassie missing her board
and no one wants to do it alone
tonight there's two hosts to split the
fee
I fired my agent can one's not me Alec
is on loan from NBC and Steve's already
done on his own go
really started and Olaf said do it